Welcome everybody to another region's podcast. This is Dr. Kevin Conner's where we go over the questions you may have on your genetic workup.
So let's get to the few questions that we had today. First one.
What does the cannabinoid system do in your body specifically to see it or one gene that we test for?
On your genetic profile.
So that what has become known as the endocannabinoid system in your body is in fact,
numerous cannabinoid receptors, so you have receptors on nearly every cell of your body for cannabinoids.
So cannabinoid samples commonly thought to be in marijuana and hemp, but actually cannabinoids are a chemical that are found in a lot of different works.
And those then attached to it affect those receptors. So it affect on the different receptors cannabinoid receptors on the different cells have to do with what that cell does.
So it's not always the same effect. Now, there's a lot of different cannabinoid receptors in the study of these is ongoing.
So specifically the CNR1 gene that we test for that's a cannabinoid receptor that's found in the brain and in other parts of the body.
So let's talk a little bit about the CNR1 gene that has been probably one of the most researched cannabinoid genes and what that receptor does.
So that gene, if if a person has a lot of defects on that gene, the person, remember, just because you have a lot of defects on a gene doesn't need you're going to have the symptoms of that gene not working at all. So just keep that in mind.
However, going that you have a lot of defects on that gene family, because this is a family of several dozen genes. So knowing that you have a lot of defects on those that family of genes can help you understand some things that can help you change lifestyle things.
So what you would want to do knowing you have CNR1 gene defects is you would want to be more careful with the use of cannabinoids, specifically with the use of marijuana.
Or, you know, maybe even CBD. So being careful of that, I mean, they have found that people with a lot of CNR1 gene defects can end up having more issues with addictions.
So more addictive type personality. So some people have said, long before we knew about genes, back in the 80s and 90s, we used to talk about some people have more addictive personalities, maybe they're in their family, they more easily get addicted to alcohol or they more easily get addicted to drugs and they know that because they have that history of their family.
We're more careful about those things with the CNR1 gene defect. Some studies have shown that a person can be more prone to substance disorders.
So that would be good to know that so that you can maybe, especially since now when marijuana is becoming legal everywhere.
You don't see mainly and the recreational use of that has is becoming acceptable in society. It's not outside the cultural nor of anymore.
Knowing if you have a lot of defects, you might want to shy away from that just because hey, just like okay, let's say my dad was an alcoholic and my several uncles were alcoholics and my grandpa was an alcoholic.
That's why I've decided to stay away from alcohol, not that I have any alcohol issue right now, but I don't want to have an alcohol issue. You don't need a genetic profile to know that.
So you should make decisions based upon ancestry.
So, but knowing you have this gene defect, that's one thing you should be aware of. This gene defect is also been involved with people with some emotional mood disorders.
So, if you notice that you tend to be more neurotic, which where you get stuck on something or OCD-ish, more argumentative, hard to see other people's point of view.
Then, you know, we don't want to blame things on our genes, but it can tie to that. It can point to some of that. You also look not only just at that gene, whatever you're looking at genes, you don't just look at that gene, you look at other genes.
That's why that's why in our genetic profile, we put the C and R1 gene in with the neurotransmitter genes because the neurotransmitter genes tie a lot to mood and mood disorders.
So, like, if I have a lot of MAOA genes, you know, the MAO gene defects, I can produce excess serotonin real easy or not produce enough serotonin so I can lead to depression or I can lead to anger outbursts and disagreeableness.
So, knowing that, you know, you can make some lifestyle changes to help protect yourself.
So, if you have a lot of defects in a lot of the neurotransmitter genes, you just need to be more careful about things that could set it off.
You go, okay, well, what do you mean? What do you mean? Well, even food allergies can set that off.
Even, you know, excess sugar can set it off. Be aware of triggers that change your mood.
Are there things that after I eat this, I feel depressed or exposures, after I'm exposed to mold, I feel, you know, anxious or I have a lot of OCD issues or I have a lot of anger issues.
What sets you off? Look for triggers that maybe set you off.
The truth is, a lot of people, a majority of people you could say have a lot of defects in their neurotransmitter genes and things can trigger them or set them off.
So, look for triggers. A good course to take is the autoimmune course because that really digs into looking for triggers that can trigger your immune function that can compound and worsen an autoimmune disease.
Well, it's the same way with neurotransmitters. Well, like I say in several of the videos, if you have MAOA defects, you don't want to be taking excess methyl groups, like which have been so common with that your paths and powerpractors telling people, oh, you have an MTHFR defects.
So, you need to get on methyl folate and methyl comolamine right away and you should, they're putting these people on relatively high doses of that.
Well, not looking downstream and other genes. If you have other defects in the biopter and pathway gene, which are all your neurotransmitter genes, that can be the exact trigger that sets that off and causes you to go into rage or anger or OCD.
Or depression or sadness or, you know, so look at the things that trigger it. It can be in foods that you're into, it can be in supplements you're taking, so just be careful of that.
Well, that kind of ties to this question. Can you explain how to balance neurotransmitters with food? For example, symptom of depression and lack of motivation. Does that mean low serotonin? What foods would balance this?
I do have a blog post about this on the course that you can look at, but it's not as simple as that.
It really goes back to looking for what triggers you because in inflammatory process in your gut can trigger a neurotransmitter imbalance.
So, that's pretend I have a gluten sensitivity that I've never addressed and I am still eating gluten.
And every time I eat gluten, it's causing this inflammatory process in my gut. And that's going to cause inflammation in my brain.
Whether or not I have CLM, TTD defects, MAOA gene defects, or cannabinoid defects, or whether I have excess or low amount of neurotransmitters, it can set off and worsen my condition.
So, it's not so bad or I'm like, okay, I'm going to eat more of this because I have this defect. It's not as simple as that. You have to look at, you have to go back to the triggers.
And I know I keep using that, but that is really the key. That's the key to managing an autoimmune disease, and that's a key to managing mood disorders.
And you have to experiment. Somebody with depression goes on a supplement with lithium, and oh my gosh, it helps balance them like the BH4 assist product we have.
It has relatively high a lot of lithium in there, and that can really help balance their mood and balance their thinking, but another person it could just be the thing that tips them over and it makes it worse.
So, as much as I wish there was just a secret formula that you just do this and this and this and this, if you have this sentiment, it's just like a algorithm that you can follow and a chart that you just do.
It's never that simple. That's why, you know, that's why you have to practice and experiment with yourself because, you know, two people could have the exact same genetic picture and one person does really well with lithium.
Then another person does well with like a dopamine type stimulation. So, you just have to experiment with things so don't buy a lot of anything.
You've got to try different things and see what helps balance you.
But it's more than ever. It's lots of times it's not just a supplement or it's not just diet. You have to look at the triggers. That's the people most of the time when they're looking at the genetics.
That's one thing that they miss. They think that it's just going to be a supplement that's going to solve their problem or specific diet that's going to solve their problem. You have to look at other triggers to can be environmental triggers can be toxins in their environment.
I've had people where they can't seemingly get better but to have mercury fillings they had to get the mercury fillings out and to detox that before they could get better or people that were exposed to mold in their house.
They could never get better until they dealt with that mold in their house because they had high level of like a toxins in their body.
So that bichotoxid toxicity was constantly a trigger in their body that no matter what they did dietarily or supplement wise could never get over that.
It was always throwing off inflammation of their brain causing a neurotransmitter imbalance and causing mood disorders.
So as much as we'd like to keep it simple you got to keep digging to find out what are your triggers what else could be an imbalance that you have to deal with.
So that's why on the course of your kids course you can run those other labs through our local lab store.
So you can run a bichotox test that's a really good test to run because that is a common trigger is bichotoxid.
So there are toxins for bones exposure. It couldn't even be bone exposure from 10 years ago.
Next question. When I have ones on a gene, does that mean it's bad? So remember, no, so one is a single leal defector two means that you have a double leal defector typically that's worse now some defects can be beneficial.
Like the defects on your black taste genes for milk if you have a double leal defector both of those you actually make more lactase and you'd actually be able to break down the sugar and milk better, but that doesn't mean you don't have a case scene problem which is the protein in milk and that's where 99% of milk allergies come from is the protein.
But most genes, if you have a one or two, that means the genes for work not quite as well. So there's going to be hindrance to that gene pathway. It's not going to work as well. And it's not going to be to our advantage.
So happy to one is quite common. So I wouldn't really worry about the ones under today for five hours, the twos that you are more concerning.
But it is really the big picture that's the most concerning. So if I have a gene family with six genes in it, then I have ones or twos on each gene.
And that's a concern to think about and look into and what can I do to support this? Am I having issues that this gene could possibly cause if I'm not that don't worry about it, but if I am that maybe look at the triggers, look at ways to support it nutritionally and everything.
But if you have a gene family with five or six genes and you have a couple of ones, I wouldn't worry about it at all.
It's the ones where you have a collaboration on problems of all those genes, the most of the genes in that gene family.
Okay, hope this was helpful. We'll get us up on the site and get this out to share. Thanks so much.